make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
okay so we are continuing on with swords
of x and in this video we're picking up
with x-force
yes we are in the continuation of this
battle so
the swords of x event it gets a little
wonky here right like i always thought
it would actually be a duel with swords
like strictly with swords apparently
that's not really the case
well at the start of this whole thing
the score is a rocco five kakoa three we
end up having a rocko getting getting a
six point then they get a seventh point
then they get an eighth point and kakoa
just keeps falling behind and it's these
various weird and wonky competitions
right like who can push a boulder up a
hill
or like who can who can basically
outswim monsters and survive
uh you have an eating contest where you
get foods from the crooked world there's
a dance-off which apparently uh
cipher does amazingly well right he
absolutely crushes it so he gets a point
um there it's like pin row steps that
they have to navigate through
uh they have to put together a puzzle
right so like krakow gets a win on that
because i guess the forces of morocco
aren't the sharpest tool in the shed
well either way it was
had to be done because forces from the
same side but then like you end up
having a runway
walk off which i don't even know that
was really like i guess it was a contest
in terms of like even i don't know i
don't really do runways i know there's a
show
about runways anyway uh storm crushes it
right and a lot of that's attributed to
the fact that it's because she might be
drunk but like consistently across the
board they're just kind of like these
wonky
and goofy competitions right they're
just sort of weird and almost
nonsensical the other thing about this
is that you end up having brian braddock
who's still kind of continuing on he's
within the crooked market itself and
kind of continuing on and a little
still a little brushed about the fact
that like betsy braddock's basically
dead right and so you end up having him
met by saturnine and saturnine who again
refers to him as captain britain he
basically disregards that says i'm not
captain britain don't call me that she
ultimately says like the title is yours
and
if you won't come around to being
captain britain willingly
then fury will work right and she
basically seems to have the furies at
her back now one of the other things
that goes on here and is something that
i'm not 100 sure i'm on the fence about
is you have jim jasper's encountering
captain britain again but captain
britain doesn't really seem to give any
indication that he knows who he is and
it would have been a cool little a cool
little nod
um in the sense that you you would have
jim jasper's like it's good to see you
again cap i'm sorry things ended so
weird last time but you know
you tried to kill me and everything it
would have been cool to see that right
just kind of a little reference to the
crooked world from back in the day it
may be that it's just kind of like you
know marvel doesn't really care or
hickman doesn't really care i don't
really know but it would have been a
cool
little nod you know to see because i
love that story so much and i love the
character of jim jasper's because he's
just so broken and overpowered
you end up having this thing where it's
basically a race between red root
and brian braddock and red rood is of
course more or less a shrub and she's
super
slow but in the midst of all this when
when uh when imagine jasper says like
you'll be able to find the finish line
around here somewhere right you look
hard enough you can find anything in the
crooked market including a finish line
once the gunfire goes off and brian
braddock starts running he's immediately
set upon by these furies right these
furies all immediately go after him
because it's basically saturnine working
against the work against brian braddock
and the forces of krakowa uh because
brian raddick won't basically won't be
her guy right he just won't go with her
right he just refuses to bend the knees
so to speak and to you know be the
whatever it is that saturnine wants out
of him right a concubine i don't
i don't really know regardless red root
basically begins a process of just kind
of of passing him up and of course she's
kind of walking and walking but she ends
up bumping into this table
and shatters a crystal that happens to
land at the foot of jim jasper's and he
just kind of says everything has a cost
of the market right
everything now of course she continues
on blissfully unaware of what's
happening
and then ultimately crosses the finish
line which is something like
five feet away from them now saturday of
course does this just for the sake of
giving
the point to a rocco right so she's it's
again like the the contest
is basically rigged but where brian
braddock is basically subdued jim jasper
starts talking to red rude and says okay
so like now there's the matter of your
debt and she's like what are you talking
about he's like you shattered a crystal
right this rare crystal
idol of bamboo right crafted from the
salt of an
umba ghonian princesses tears i don't
really know what that is but he's
basically like it was priceless right
everything here has a price if you break
something that's priceless you have to
deal with it accordingly and so
basically with the whole process being
done and saturnine sending the furies
away which is
also a little bit disappointment that
brian braddock doesn't recognize who
they are then in turn
jim jaspers uses his ability to
manipulate reality and shrinks redroot
down and encases her in glass
and leaves her there like she's
literally just kind of stuck there
forever more uh seemingly
never to be able to escape and so with
that being the case you in turn have
a saturnine who basically says like you
have done untold damage
to the crooked market right i mean
there's no calculating how much damage
you've done here
everything here is irreplaceable right
so if redroot was shrunk down for what
she did
god only knows what jim jasper is going
to do to you unless of course you ask
for my help if you ask for my help then
jim jaspers won't do anything to you now
whether or not that's what he did
we're not given a definitive answer to
instead what we end up doing is
switching over to
these two interesting scenarios that go
on in terms of part of this contest
right the first one comes in the form of
magic where she has to answer a riddle
if she gets the answer right
uh then of course she gets a point if
she gets it wrong then she loses right
so the the riddle is
uh a white rabbit pulled out of a black
top hat and a spell cast by a wizard
and the very life force of saturnine
what am i and she basically says that's
an easy one magic and it's spelled
m-a-g-i-k and she's wrong
so she got that one wrong because she's
an idiot uh but with with wolverine and
uh
and and white sword it's a little bit
different they have to stand in front of
a mirror and they have to observe the
faces of
all the people they've killed the first
one to look away loses
the first one to blink loses wolverine
actually ends up crying and ends up
blinking now this is designed to kind of
compare these two characters between
each other the white sword
relishes and loves the idea of battle
and doesn't really care much about the
people that he's taking out with
wolverine
it's a whole different beast because the
people that he's lost in some ways have
actually been a result of his own
actions specifically his wife dying
the son of dakin right she died
partially because of wolverine's actions
himself right he kind of led to that
situation taking place the people that
sabertooth killed over the course of his
life like his actions inevitably seemed
to lead to that and so
because of that like he you know a lot
of the losses he sustained have been a
defining part of his character but also
crushed him at the same time and so
that's why wolverine ends up being the
first to blink wolverine loses so the
score now stands
aroco 15 kakoa five right they're
getting absolutely decimated and things
only really seem to get worse right they
have these things called the rock sirens
of uh of clevermore that nobody that
almost no one can really resist their
call
and gorgon goes running up on it right
just gets naked starts taking his
clothes off like yeah man me and the
rocks
we're gonna get it on and then from
there you end up switching over to
merlin who presents a challenge to the
horseman war
and to captain britain and says your
challenge is to kill the kitten that's
your task and like war
just immediately goes to kill it and
brian braddock's like no you can't kill
that kitten that by
that in that moment is basically him
acquiescing it's showing he wouldn't do
it krakowa loses right so a rocco 17
kakoa five and that's kind of how these
things continue but then you pick up
with storm
and you pick up with the horsemen of
death and the two of them you know storm
really kind of seems to come too
after having been intoxicated right
having been drunk and they brought to
the realm of
severleth right kind of like this this
realm of vampires and so on
and the contest is again basically a
fight to the death and where storm
initially says no we need to postpone
this because something's wrong with me
whatever it was that i had
that bar of of jim jasper's i'm
effectively drunk now the response of
death is i mean no but i mean you can
but if you do then you'll have to
forfeit and that's when she realizes he
intentionally did this to her right he
got her drunk
zapped her power and now like she's
gonna have to fight in traditional
hand-to-hand combat the thing about this
though
is storm is no slouch and she's also one
of the best fighters in marvel
not the best best where she's not like
in the top five or probably even the top
ten but she's a really really really
good fighter and able to hold her own
and as she's fighting this conflict
against uh against death she gets the
upper hand and actually destroys his
sword in the process and so in response
to that
death removes his helmet and he
basically intends to use the death stare
now the death stare is basically those
individuals who look upon it effectively
die
right if you if you glance if you look
at that look into his face his stare
will kill you hence the reason why he
was given the name death but he's not
immune to his own powers he's just
highly resistant to them and this is
this comes in the form that when he
emits the death stare and that kind of
substance comes out
and intends to kill storm she reflects
it back at him using her sword because
her sword is
pristine and it's basically a mirror and
so it basically kind of you know
incapacitates him for a moment she
plunges the sword through his chest
and kills a horseman of death this of
course leads to all the vampires
basically tearing him apart and the
point goes to cocoa so at this point
right now because of storm they've
managed to bounce back but they're still
losing terribly right now the score is
17
morocco six to kakoa no earthly clue
how in the world they could possibly
make that up but that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you